[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today well
we're doing something we've never done
on the Ramsey sh uh we sent Jade washaw
and Ken Coleman to Washington DC they've
been up there for about the last 48
hours with the student loans restarting
uh talking to the man on the street uh
and some uh women on the street and some
uh people that should be on the street
co- Congressman no I'm kidding and uh
they're hey learning about
um what's happening with the student
loans so what are you guys finding out
up
there well Dave thanks for having us on
so we spent yesterday the full day
moving between Georgetown uh the campus
talking to a lot of students about their
current debt situation and then we moved
to the mall in between the Lincoln
Memorial and the Washington Monument and
talked to so many different people it
was a lot of fun and we heard I think
one key theme was that people really
believe collectively no matter how they
vote or what they believe in from a
religious standpoint the message
was tuition is too high it's going up
too quickly it's
outsized and that was a very interesting
theme Jade I agree you know and
something else they knew tuition was
high but when we asked the students so
how much are you paying each semester
how much are you paying each year when
you come out of college how much total
debt do you think you'll have and it was
really interesting they kind of seemed
in a fog about how much debt they were
going to leave with um one guy even said
to us he said you know I've got bigger
fish to fry I've got enough to worry
about right now I'm getting my MD you
know I I'll worry about that you know
when I get out of med school and I
thought oh my gosh he estimated that
he'd probably come out with about three
or
$400,000 of debt Dave so that's pretty
crazy yeah and his starting salary he
thinks $60,000 so uh it's that kind of
story that was pretty synonymous
everybody thinks that tuition has got to
be addressed so tuition's too high
though um so they're saying tuition is
too high but they don't know how much it
is that's right that's right very
interesting at Georgetown a lot of these
kids yeah well now it's interesting at
Georgetown obviously uh we saw a pattern
too where these students were saying
they didn't know how much they actually
were going to owe because Mom and Dad
took out the loans or handled all the
details so that was kind of scary as
well and there's another piece to it uh
Dave and John not only did they believe
that tuition was too high everybody
agreed that there's a major problem here
and we asked them specifically well what
do you think about forgiveness you know
Biden these administ ations offering
forgiveness do you think it's a good
idea and here's what I thought was
really remarkable they all thought hey
it would be nice to have forgiveness all
of us would love for somebody to come in
and take care of our debt but they all
agreed that it was kind of a selfish you
know it was a selfish want that
ultimately it probably wasn't best for
people for the government uh for people
in large to offer that forgiveness a
because it's not fair for everybody and
B because of the tax implication of
burdening you know others who maybe
didn't even take out student loans with
the bill
is what do they I struggle with the cost
part because it feels like yet another
way of passing the blame onto somebody
else and um I can drive by a car
dealership like a Porsche dealership and
the prices are going to be expensive and
the car is worth the money I mean it's
expensive but it's up to me to be
responsible enough to know I can't
afford a Porsche so I'm going to move on
um did any of those students that you
met with own the fact that they're going
to a school that they can't afford they
even know how much it
cost well there's a question you make a
very good point John uh but I think it's
different between the student who wants
to go into social work who goes and gets
a really expensive degree and is only
making 4
$45,000 and then the med student that we
talked to there's only one way to get
that Med degree and medical school is
crazy and to give you real numbers
because these why is a medical doctor
only going to make
60k well he's talking about the intern
years uh is what he said as a card
cardiac so yeah so he's got an intern
for 3 or four years but let me point
this out because John brings up a good
point but if we look at 2010 to 2022 the
cost of tuition Rose over 12% each year
when you had inflation only moving up at
about 2 and a half% so it is ridiculous
these college and universities keep
raising the price because they've got an
audience who just keeps getting the loan
the Federal Loan program and these
colleges and universities are colluding
that's a simple fact oh no question
about it if you cut the money off from
the student loans suddenly the price
increases would go away I mean because
they wouldn't have they wouldn't have
students willing or able to pay what
they're charging so yeah they'd have to
re they have to address the problem but
but that goes back to Dave what you've
been saying for the last year which is
the student loan bailout program is
almost beside the point we deal with
that after you don't deal with the flood
without turning the faucet off first
right at first you got to deal with the
faucet
and if they were serious about helping
young people and they were serious about
helping students and serious about not
saddling future generations with
trillions of dollars of debt they would
deal with that up front instead of you
know bailing water and letting it
continue to run you can't keep making
the loans that's intellectually
dishonest when you know when we're got a
crisis on our hands of student loan Epic
Proportions here so uh did you run into
people whose loans are starting back
today yes it's so funny that you
mentioned that we got the opportunity to
talk to several folks I talked to a girl
her name was Ariel and she was excited
to talk to her she had strong feelings
about student loans and forgiveness and
she was really banking Dave on
forgiveness from the Biden
Administration and when she didn't get
it you know she's been seeing her
interest pile up obviously since the
start of September and she told me she
said Jade I've already seen $1,000 acrew
in interest from September 1st until
today she said it's the equivalent of
three full payments almost and she said
said it's blowing my mind how quickly
this interest is uring she's an ed she's
an educator herself and she's like I
don't see a way out and so you know I
was able to talk to her I said hey what
if I told you that every day you know
several times a week on the Ramsey show
we hear people come in doing their
debt-free Scream they paid off 70,000
80,000 220,000 whatever number of debt
people are doing it every day they've
just got to have the tools in order to
make it happen and honestly they've got
to believe that it can happen and I feel
like that's the missing piece uh kin
that we've seen and when Jade asked her
that she lit up there was so much hope
that just took over her whole body it
was a really cool moment so um I'm
curious in my mind there's 44 million
people today that have a payment due for
the first time in three years uh in many
cases a large payment it's going to take
a chunk out are you is I feel like it I
don't know why I feel like we're the
only ones talking about this like the
like the typical person in America's
talking about it but I haven't run into
anybody in the media that's gotten that
today is a big freak deal economically
societally everything else are you
running into people out are going my God
what a
mess not really when we were on the
college campus it was interesting Ken on
the college campuses it's almost like
they're just in a blur they have no idea
this is happening I probably talked to
five different students who I said hey
do you understand the significance of
today I said do you understand student
loans have been on pause for three years
they're finally starting back and they
were like I don't know what you're
talking about yeah that's right it's
business as usual Dave it's not a big
story because quite frankly it's so old
it's been around forever and I think the
American people have lost a lot of Hope
to where it's not a sensational story
anymore and that's what's really a crime
you know this has to be addressed from
the leadership level in Congress in the
white house it's a crime that they're
giving this money away to people who
can't afford it and then charging them
crazy interest this is not about helping
people get educated this is a hidden tax
on the American people in my opinion and
there's a little bit of oness can on the
parent in this situation because a lot
of the students we talk to they said
from their own mouth hey I think my
parents took out a loan I think they
signed for it I'm pretty sure they're
taking care of the bill and you know to
which I said hey you better have that
conversation and have it fast because
when it comes time to pay the piper you
need to know who's on the hook well and
Jade you bring up a great Point there's
a mill there's millions and millions of
parents that use the college their kid
got into to give themsel a pat on the
back and to be able to tell their
friends in church and the community
that's right instead of having a
realistic honest conversation about hey
child what do you actually want to do
when you grow up and what is the best
path for you and our family there they
just want to run and say hey my kid got
into Georgetown my kid's going to
Georgetown that's right forget the fact
that it's going to be 40 Years of paying
that thing off yeah what a mess what a m
absolutely right John y well Jade
warshaw Ken Coleman in Washington DC
reporting live on the first day that the
student loan payments kicked back in
officially as actually technically as of
last night but uh there you go and um
man we're starting to see some movement
out there in the marketplace and we
thought we wanted to be right on the
front lines